Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn.
It's time for the Monday
morning podcast from Monday,
January 11th, 2016 what's
going on? How I yeah,
I was at going, I'm in a great
fucking mood. I don't know why.
You know what? I haven't boozed in like
fucking, I don't know what it's been.
I don't t nine 10 days
or something like that.
I did have a sip of wine last night,
but I don't really consider that booze
and you know, the way I go after it, um,
my wife, so you know, something, we, it's
funny when I, when I stopped drinking,
my wife always tries to
get me back to drinking,
not to get drunk or anything. She just
is like, you're so fucking, you know,
I drive her so fucking nuts
that I just think sometimes,
you know,
if she wasn't such a good person,
I think she would try and like drug me
every night like around supper. Right.
Make a little dinner, be like, how
is that honey? Hello? Look at you.
You look sleepy. And like, I have no idea.
Like, she just put some shit in my food,
not to like kill me, just
to sort of sedate me. Um,
but uh, anyways, but I haven't drank
in like 10 days or something. Wow.
That really made my head go somewhere
like, wow, that's kind of fucked up.
She does that. Um, but yeah, I
haven't drank in like 10 days.
I, uh, I'm feeling good and that,
so what happens is nice slowly,
you know, I start to eat better. I'm
starting my day off with the old, uh,
from the old country thing,
you know,
you little fucking water
at room temperature,
which should make you keg if you're any
kind of a fucking human being, but a,
you get used to it with some lemon and
then a little cayenne pepper in it.
And then I take a,
I let that settle in me.
Then I get a couple of
scoops of a Greek yogurt,
the all natural stuff that actually
kind of tastes like sour cream.
And the first time I ate it,
I was like,
this is the worst shit I've ever
tasted because I was used to the, uh,
the crack baby yogurt that I've been
eating my whole life that has like fucking
40 bags of sugar in it, you know,
and you yogurt, you'll like, yeah,
I mean,
the amount of sugar that's in fucking
regular yoga Humani you should fucking
snort it. I mean, it's literally
like, I mean, I'm not glad he,
I still fucking love it, but, uh,
the Greek shit took me a minute and
now I'm actually, uh, I like it, man.
If I drink this shit and just
have a couple of scoops of that,
it kind of fills me up.
And that's kind of the big thing is you
become an old fuck like me. It's just,
just somehow getting the hunger to go
away without doing damage to yourself,
you know,
and then walking around and burn a few
calories before you go to the next one.
You know, and I know this
is a bunch, you know,
hopefully some younger listeners listening
to this judging Mikko this is this
old fart talking about
fucking lemon water,
Cayenne pepper and fucking Greek
yogurt. Well, you know something.
If you're lucky enough,
you'll live long enough.
If we don't fuck up something or something
bad doesn't happen to, you know, to,
to by age and you know,
it's good to start healthy
habits now. Fuck. Shut up bill.
What do you the fucking first lady,
you know what I'm doing right now?
I'm doing shit that like a first
lady does right now. I'm actually,
let's get in shape.
Kids.
How about you go outside for 10 minutes
a day and you just do some jumping jacks?
Can you fucking believe that they've got
to tell kids to go out and play piano?
That's how fucking insane
video games have got.
I mean,
if I made video games and I actually
saw Michelle Obama on TV begging kids to
try to not have their first
cardiac incident by the
time they were in the third
grade, I mean I, I would tear
up and just be like, I did it.
You know,
I am so fucking great at my job.
I've made children stop playing outside,
you know.
Do you think there's like at the Alec
Baldwin of the video game industry,
you know, from Glengarry Glen Ross
Ross coming in just screaming at him.
Okay.
Yeah. But kids, I cause
to have a heart attack,
seven fuck Yo. Right.
She's screaming at him
trying to get them to,
we haven't done our fucking jobs till
every kid has a fucking pacemaker by the
seventh grade. Um, I dunno.
Anyways. Yeah. So I'm trying to get back
in shape. So, uh, I've been stoned sober.
So yesterday I got my, uh, my, my
first massage in like, I dunno,
like two years.
Whenever I get a massage afterwards,
I always think like, I got
to start doing this, man,
this is great for an old fart like
me, you know? And then he'd come home,
you crush the waters,
you get all the toxins out here or
whatever yoga shit they tell you to do.
And um, but the, I know this always
happened in my own fucking do this.
You know what? Once, once a
month [inaudible] you know,
fucking, you haven't worked out my
fucking back, like my whole right.
I don't know what,
like I have a little curvature
of the spine and the lady's like,
where are the problem areas? Right? And
of course your brain always goes my dick.
But you know,
it's illegal place.
They seem to be having a problem in the,
uh,
central pelvic area on the
frontal lobe. Um, I'm like,
I never even noticed it either.
I was like my right shoulder,
my right forearm and my right
foot. And I was just like, wow,
how fucked up is my right side?
And then I realized all of them,
all of those injuries I got
from playing drums, you know,
my right forearm from fucking
holding the stick wrong.
I Dunno what I'm doing with my shoulders
probably after I fuck up another field
looking at the bass player.
And shrugging like, I'm sorry.
I mean I tried to get back on
one, right. And then my foot,
I fucked that up years ago trying to
get my bass drum fast as John Bottoms,
you know, which I never even remotely
achieved. I just had the lifetime pain.
You know,
every time I take a step,
I'm always reminded of what a wonderful
drummer John Bonham is. Um, so anyways,
uh, I did that. Um, with the lovely Nia,
that's always a good thing to do it, you
know, you go in there with your wife,
then you don't feel like a dirt bag.
Cause anytime I go to get a massage,
I always feel like a dirt bag.
There's just no way not to feel like
a fucking complete piece of shit.
When you walk in, they're
like, yeah, Hey, I want you to,
I want you to work out the kinks there,
sweetheart. You know what I mean? Oh,
wait a minute. What am I talking about?
I got a massage and fucking, Nah,
Milwaukee, no, I didn't.
No, I did not. That was the steam.
That was a steam. That's right. Oh,
that's right. That's right.
Yeah. I guess I haven't,
I'd like two fucking years and they
always do the same thing, wouldn't they?
When they put my hands on my
back, they just go, wow. Wow.
Do you have a lot of stress? Has
it been a while? It's like I, yeah,
if your back feels like gravel.
So anyways,
we did that and then we came home and um,
we made a Mario Batali
is a Lasagna A's and uh,
it was fucking delicious. Homemade Pasta,
homemade pasta things and all that.
I got to get my homemade pasta game up.
I tried to make the spinach pasta
and the pasta was definitely green,
but he could still see the
chunks of a spinach in there,
you know what I mean? So what does that
mean? Did I not need the dough enough?
Was because it was frozen spinach,
like it's said to be like the, uh,
the recipe said to me, am I saying
that right? Like the recipe said,
said to be, what the fuck does
that mean? Like the rest of the,
we said it should be. I think that's
what I was trying to say, but um,
you know,
and I dried it out.
Yeah.
And maybe I just didn't dice it up
enough. I have no idea. But, um,
I'm actually psyched that, uh, the
consistency though, I can get that down.
I might have needed it needed to knead
it a little bit more. I don't know.
Is there any,
uh,
higher qualified people out there that
could help me out on how to make the
right spinach pasta because I watched
some videos and I still fucked the thing
up.
But anyways,
so we did all of that and meanwhile
I was watching like the playoff games
playoffs and I'm fucking
great games this weekend.
Heartbreakers but just fucking,
just great games with also that,
that creeping sadness that I always
have when the playoffs are here.
That it's just like did another regular
season. Go buy that fucking fast.
Okay.
God Damn it. It's going to
be over there. Not a month.
It's going to be fucking over this
time. Next month is good. This,
I'm not even gonna say, cause there's
gonna be two fucking depressing. Um,
however, I have gotten totally into the
Celtics and NBA hoop with my Bruins.
So I mean, I got a little game almost
every night sometimes too, but anyways,
so let's go through them. Let's go
throw him. Is that be fucking Douche?
Who doesn't like sports is going to
roll their eyes just fast forward like
fucking 40 minutes and you'll be
safe. Um, the first one I saw,
I think I want, I taped all of them.
Um, so I watched them at weird times.
I watched, uh, the second
half of the original Texas,
the Kansas City chiefs, just absolutely
dominating the, uh, the new Texans.
And I actually tweeted that
out to an AH, on Twitter. Um,
and I actually got a ton of shit
for it. People are like, oh,
what are you trying to show off your
sports knowledge? It's like, no,
I like Sharon it. I love when people do
stuff like that and I am a sports nerd.
Okay. I'm not acting like I played at a
professional level. I just love that shit.
So I'm going to take you through it.
For those of you didn't know that the
chiefs were originally called the Texas.
They actually played in Dallas, Texas. Um,
when the AFL first started and when
the AFL first came out, the NFL,
the established league publicly
laughed at them and said,
these guys are crazy. They'll,
this will never work. Ha Ha,
ha, whatever. I, you know,
are you nervous now? We're not nervous
at all. We're just going to do, you know,
the American people know where the
quality football is that right?
That's what they said publicly.
And then behind the scenes,
as much as they may or may have not
believed that they then hedged their bets
and they wanted to try to
sabotage the AFL as much as they
could before it even got started.
So the AFL, how many fucking teams did
they had? They had the Boston Patriots,
the buffalo bills,
the New York titans.
Yeah.
Uh, the Dallas Texans,
the Minnesota Vikings,
and I'll get back to that before
you say that. I'm wrong on that.
They had the Minnesota Vikings.
I used to know this by heart.
Denver Broncos.
Oakland Raiders.
Okay.
San Diego chargers. I'm sorry.
The Los Angeles chargers.
Yeah.
And a dolphin's weren't in it.
Bengals weren't in it.
Who the fuck else has left? Bears.
Lions. Yeah, something like that.
I probably forgot a team or two.
And so the owner with the
most money was Lamar Lundy,
I believe that was his name.
I didn't look the shit up again,
but I read this whole book on it.
Lamar Lundy,
and he was the wealthiest of all owners.
So basically this guy could hold out
the longest in this new crazy venture.
All right, so Dave, how
they attack the fucking AFL?
They did it on two different levels.
The Dallas Texans were
owned by Lamar Lundy,
the most wealthiest of all the owners.
So what they the NFL did was
they awarded Dallas a team,
which became the Dallas cowboys.
So for a season or two, I forget,
I didn't look it up as I said that you
could either go see the Dallas cowboys or
the Dallas,
Texas now the Dallas cowboys,
as much as they were
an expansion franchise,
you could go down and watch them get
the shit kicked out of him. You know,
by Johnny Unitas. Jim Brown
or you know, Frank Gifford.
And while these guys, you
know, all these legends,
the fucking Green Bay
packers would come to town.
You get to see Vince Lombardi and the,
the, the early days of the packer sweep,
you could see all this professional level
talent or you could go across town and
go see the Dallas Texans,
a bunch of nobodies playing a bunch of
nobodies cause they want to establish it.
So obviously that completely,
um, that's a no brainer.
As a sports fan,
you're going to go see the NFL team and
go see all these stars that you've been
watching on TV. So, uh,
that completely fucked them.
And they had to move to Kansas
City and they became the chiefs.
They kept their colors though.
But they were originally called the Texas,
but they gave up the name.
And then the Minnesota Vikings,
which I did not know. I didn't know
any of that shit till I read the book.
The Minnesota Vikings were
originally going to be an AFL team.
So at the NFL did was not
only award Dallas a team,
they also went to the owners of the
Minnesota Vikings and said, hey,
do you want to just join the NFL
and not be part of the AFL? Come on,
we're an established leak.
And of course they said, hey,
fuck you guys and your new venture.
We're going to fuck a fuck the
whole going against the NFL,
we're going to join them. So
that's what they did. They, uh,
they opened a franchise across town
from the wealthiest owner and then they
stole one of their teams that,
that was their two moves as they publicly
laughed at the AFL. So there you go.
There's a little fucking little
little history from all freckles.
Um, but having said that, you
know, baby, they got him back,
but I guess they'd have to
beat the fucking cowboys.
And they're also part of the NFL.
So a congratulations to the chiefs and
evidently they're playing the Patriots is
what I got from some of the tweets. And,
uh, I am not a comfortable Patriot fan.
No Patriot fan who's been watching
the Patriots is, you know,
we had a lot of losses towards the end
of the year. Um, I'm hoping, you know,
we're going to get some help
back on our offensive line. Um,
either way it's going to be,
even if we were healthy,
it would have been a brutal
day. Cause, uh, you know,
Andy Reid is no slouch as much
as the guy gets a ton of shit.
I mean the guy's been to a bunch of,
uh,
NFC championship games and shit like that.
He has been there before, but you know,
you do need the players.
You do need the ownership.
You need all of that type of shit
to try and to try to succeed.
So congratulations to them.
And I'm,
I am by no means comfortable
with next week. Um,
and you know, also, you know,
the chief speak the Seattle Seahawks
as far as p and the loudest fans at one
point, they did it in that old
ass stadium rather than the, uh,
the stadium's Seahawks fans half that
helps him out and contains the south.
That was such a cut. But it's true. Um,
and uh, yeah, so speaking of
the Vikings and the bangles,
my condolences to fans of both teams.
I've been there,
fortunately you have not been there in
a long time. I guess the giants losses,
but I can't wine as a fan with all the
other shit that was going on. But uh,
Jesus fucking Christ.
What the fuck was that guy doing
after he picked off the ball,
walking up to the tunnel
already celebrating.
I thought fucking athletes
were were superstitious.
The fuck are you doing
right there? Yeah, right.
That's fucking unbelievable to me.
And then he's fucking sitting there.
He probably already took his God damn
cleats off and then the very next play,
what it was at two plays in,
they fumbled the fucking ball.
I had to watch this part of the game
on highlights because I taped the game.
If the one time I don't do
the extended fucking record,
this shit happens and I'm
probably to put his cleats on,
run back out on the field.
I think he was so fucking frustrated
cause he still had champagne, you know,
coursing through his veins. He was already
mentally the next week that he goes,
it's, this was the same guy, right. Goes
in and fucking knocks out that player.
Unfucking believable.
Unfucking believable. Hey,
Steeler fence. How many you shut
the game off after the interception?
Huh?
Not because you're a fair weather fan.
Just because you couldn't stomach to
watch the bangle fans jumping up and down
and having some joy. You know, I,
I'd forgive you if you did that.
I'd forgive you if you walked away.
You know,
or if you already started celebrating
and you turned your big fucking sausage
eaten back to the fucking TV and you
are already doing well where gay.
But uh, but uh, who do we got
next week doing all that shit.
Fucking brutal. And uh,
the Vikings, I won't even,
I don't even,
can you explain to me how you place
kicker had the laces facing you kick her
twice in one fucking
game and a playoff game
that's on fuck him. I've never, I mean,
you never see the laces in, right?
I never even knew about it.
I'm not gonna lie to you.
I didn't ever even knew about
laces out since fucking ace mature.
That's when I learned about
it. Or is it ace Ventura? Um,
Jesus. Fuck. I mean,
I watched the replay of that game and
I went on Twitter beforehand and I,
you know, I found out the vikings
one in which a fucking sucked,
but I was in the middle of, you
know, trying to make spinach pasta,
which was well beyond my cooking ability.
So, you know, I was a little fucking, uh,
got a little sideways there for a minute.
And um,
I was thinking like, what the fuck
at Man, he must make this field goal.
Okay.
And then Seattle just has a ridiculous
kickoff return and then they're able to
kick it. Oh, maybe they,
they score a touchdown or maybe
a defensive back falls down.
I had no idea that he was going
to fucking lose it. Oh my God.
Fucking brutal.
But you know what,
every championship team,
you gotta have a little bit of luck.
The first fucking Superbowl, the
Patriots won. We had the Tuck rule,
which was a fucking rule.
Everybody blames Tom Brady.
It was a blame the officials.
Oh,
now the rule rules committee for coming
up with that weird one because I say to
this day, that's a fucking
fumble. That's a fumble.
The way sugar bear Hamilton did not
interfere with Ken Stabler the year the
fucking Raiders won a super Superbowl 11.
So anybody in Oakland puts your fucking
hankies away cause I don't wanna hear
you crying about it. That was
payback for super bowl. Uh,
not super 11.
The fucking playoffs playoffs and a 77
which sugar bear Hamilton was already in
the air jumping at Ken Stabler and,
and then he lets the ball go and they
called roughing the passer and back then
it wasn't a 15 yard penalty or they put
the ball where the guy threw it and it
was the end of the game needs
through a 50 yard fucking prayer.
Ray Hamilton's already in the
fucking air lands on Ken Stabler.
They call roughing the passer and they
took the ball from like the 50 and put it
on the fucking one inch line and then the
Raiders went and won the fucking game.
So I don't want to hear anything about it,
but I am man enough to say that the
Tuck rule was fucking horseshit and, uh,
I think it's a fumble,
you know,
but I'm not expecting that level of
maturity from rate offense. You know,
a fan base that goes to the game,
you know, dressed with uh, you know,
spikes on your shoulder pads that have
been checked by security to make sure
that they're totally safe as you
make a, I'm not safe, angry face.
Um, you know, something that does bug
me. I can't stand when they fucking, um,
when people get upset that Hollywood has
the audacity have awards to have award
shows and they always talk about
the self congratulatory night. Um,
like what business doesn't have an award
show, it's just not fucking televised.
You know, if you fucking drill for oil,
you know, they have the best of, you know,
BP and all them.
They have their fucking yearly fucking
Christmas party in l bass rage and all
man at Jr.
Okay
goes Duh Clem,
Clem field that a fucking Mishawaka clam.
I'm paying for that copper all tonight.
Kevin is his wife here,
you know they do and they get
them a little fucking trophy.
They have salesmen of the month.
Shit, you work at Mcdonald's,
you can get employee of the month,
you know,
you know they have franchise of the year.
You joined the fucking cub scouts.
You tie your fucking shoes,
they give you a little badge to
so on your fucking shirt. Right?
Why isn't Hollywood allowed
to have that little fucking
okay.
Evening. What is it? Huh?
What is it that bugs you?
That there's a bunch of
hot famous ass there?
Oh Geez. I'm sorry. You
know what I want to see?
I want to see somebody go out there and
defend bill Cosby on an award show dead
serious and just fucking hold it and
never let anybody in on the joke and then
try to continue hosting
and do it in the monologue.
Let's see if they ask you back.
All right,
I'm done being a cunt. Um, PAT's
first Kansas City. No, I'm not,
and this isn't what I want to fucking
read here. I want to read, uh,
the live reads advertising. All
right. Dollar Shave Club. Every one.
Yeah,
dollar Shave Club.
Uh,
lots of players will be sporting
playoff beards now that, oh,
now that the postseasons here,
leave that to the pros kickoff a year,
right with a fresh blade.
That's why a millions
of others have joined.
Dollar Shave club.com dollar shave club
knows the key to getting the amazing
shave. What the key to getting
amazing shave is simple one,
use a fresh dollar shave club
blade to use their doctor cavities.
Easy Shave, bye. That's it.
Dollar Shave Club delivers amazing razors
right to my door for a third of the
price of those greedy
mega razor corporations.
That means listeners who switch now
can afford the luxury of shaving with a
fresh blade anytime and
save hundreds this year.
And when you combine that fresh blade
with their doctor, cavities, easy shave,
but tap it just glides.
It's unimaginably smooth.
I'm telling you it's not your average
shape foam and it won't dry out your skin,
which is great. The all natural
ingredients. Leave your skin feeling soft,
smooth and moisturized even after
the shape. Uh, take it from me.
Use a fresh dollar shave club blade
with Dr Carver's. Easy shave butter.
One time. I had to do the hours. Um,
if you want the most gentle
shave imaginable joint,
the dollar shave club.com/burr
revolution today,
that's dollar shave club.com/per.
All right, blue apron. All right.
You need to know how to cook that only.
Well, I mean, if you want to be healthy,
you need to know how to cook.
All right? Jesus Blue Apron.
You coming right out with
the generalities. Um,
not only do you feel like you
know your way around the kitchen,
but cooking at home means eating healthier
and saving money instead of ordering
expensive takeout. Again. Uh, but
where do you start? Blue Apron has,
you're covered for less than $10 per meal.
Blue Apron delivers all the fresh
ingredients you need to create home cooked
meals. Just follow the easy
step by step instructions.
Each meal can be prepared in 40
minutes or less. No more overwhelming,
overwhelming trips to the grocery
store. No more sad takeout. Plus,
you know what's great is if you
know you're dating some chicken,
she doesn't know. You know,
you're dating some guy,
whatever the fuck you doing and they
don't know that you don't know shit in the
kitchen. You know, you whip this
fucking thing together. They look at us.
Maybe somebody I can be with, you know,
if you looking for a relationship,
but maybe somebody they could fuck each
meal can be prepared in 40 minutes or
less. No overwhelming trips to the
grocery store. No more sad takeouts.
I already read that. No matter your
dietary preferences, Blue Apron,
it makes it a breeze to
discover and prepare dishes
like blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah. Right now in your
kitchen, Cook with ingredients.
MMM.
Cook with ingredients that you've never
used before. Like watermelon, radishes,
I've never heard of
that. Pharaoh, Pharaoh,
f a r r o and purple potatoes and
recipes between 500 to 700 calories.
Proportion. Delicious and
good for you. Do this.
If you're fucking working
out trying to get shaped.
This is fucking perfect right now.
You can get your first two
meals for free@blueapron.com
slash [inaudible] that's
blue apron.com/bar hi blue
apron.com/ [inaudible] blue apron.
A better way to cook. You know, it'd be
great as even if he'd, even if you're,
you know,
have a nine to five regular job.
If you start off with a decent breakfast,
you bring your fucking lunch
and then you order blue apron,
get night and y'all know it.
Did I say y'all, y'all are.
Y'All know what I'm talking about?
Dinner is what fucks your diet.
At least for me,
cause I can eat well the whole fucking
day. Whole Day, I'm doing good,
I'm doing good. And then by
fucking four o'clock I'm like, Hey,
I want some fucking potato chips
and I want some ice cream. You know,
if you could just fucking call these
cunts and have them deliver a 500 700 meal
and you just fucking eat the shit right,
then you're done.
Drink waters for the rest of the night
and have a little salary already cut up,
you know, throw spoonful of
peanut butter in there. You know,
it's going to melt off unless you have,
you know,
I know some built in excuse, you know,
like a lot of overweight people do.
Oh my metabolism's really
slow. Yeah, yeah. That and
8,000 calories a fucking day,
dude. Alright. Mv Empty
watches. Oh, you know,
we only have four this week, so why
don't I do two, one, two, let's do that.
All right, let's get back to
the thing here. Um, all right.
Uh,
Oh,
today as I'm rushing through
this fucking podcast, I'm,
I'm having somebody coming over
looking at my garage today.
I even have to whisper this shit.
I somehow talked my wife into, uh,
you know,
allowing me to have,
just have somebody come over
and take a look at the garage.
I know I did that a couple months
back, but then I got busy, but now I,
I got the person coming back again and uh,
I'm actually using her
skills,
you know, that she does with me.
That's how I ended up with a dog. Like,
we're not getting this dog,
we're just,
we're a fostering the
dog for a couple of days,
cause she knew that I'd fall in love with
the fucking dog and then that would be
hit. So it's kind of like when you
first start, start dating a woman,
um, you know when she wants
a relationship, when she
comes over to your apartment,
but she starts do is she leaves shit there
cause it gives an excuse to come back.
I mean, it's fucking nuts, right?
Like the thinking that far ahead.
All you're sitting as a look at
those debts. Oh, the fucker. Right?
That's all you're thinking.
And they're sitting there plotting.
You know what I mean?
It's like you're some fucking head coach
that has no game plan and she's across
the field like fucking Bill Walsh calling
the first 25 plays of the game. Right?
Oh, I love a football life. There's
a nice reference to use. Um,
so, you know, it's fucking hilarious.
And speaking with Patrice O'Neal
benefits coming up once again, uh,
tell you a quick Patrice story.
Um,
he was so fucking brilliant than I
remember he was dating this woman and you
know, or whatever in her and she started
leaving shit around his house and I,
I just just had brought that
up because yeah. You know,
I dated swimming, you know,
she left this shit here and she left
that. It's like, what the fuck? You know,
I only see her like, you know, once
every two weeks he's just has shit their,
so for two weeks I keep looking at
her fucking brush or the shampoo,
she left bell or whatever and it just,
I keep thinking about
her and it's annoying me
and Patrice just goes Ecos,
so throw it out.
I go, what? He goes, throw it out. I'm
going to cancel out a brush. He goes,
I would, I go get the fuck
out. He goes, yeah. He goes,
I did that and he told me his story but
there was a woman he was messing around
with and she left these toiletries
and a little bag of like, you know,
makeup and brush and all that.
Eddie,
he fucking throw it out.
And then he came back like a week and
a half later and she goes to go in the
bathroom. She's like a, she's like,
Hey, what did you do with my, uh,
my stuff? He goes, and he just plays
dumb. He goes, what stuff? She goes,
I left shampoo here, a little makeup
bay. He goes, Oh yeah, I was yours. Yeah.
He goes, yeah, I throw it out.
And she was like literally beside herself,
but actually on some level respected him
for like fucking realizing what she was
doing.
And then also I think because that early
on he clearly let her know in a very
funny fucking way that he wasn't
looking for a relationship and uh,
that she was able to relax and
kind of be thinking that, oh,
we're just fucking all right. I wanted
a little more, he doesn't at least,
but he let her know so fucking
early on that it didn't really hurt,
you know? Does that make sense? I mean,
I don't, maybe I'm speaking for her,
but I guess I am, but whatever.
Either way it was fucking funny.
Jesus was at the fucking worse.
I literally just jumped out of the plane
and pull the fucking rip cord on that
story. Sorry. It's been awhile. It's been
awhile since I told that story, hasn't it?
Or have I told it before? I don't fucking
know. So anyway, so I'm kind of using
the same fucking tricks that my wife used
that got me the dog I'm using with her
because, um, we're going to like,
hey, why am I whispering here?
Like she can't just listen to the fucking
podcast. Fucking I eat that sometimes.
Like how dumb I am. It's just
really fucking, so anyways,
what I want to do is I have this
old school fucking, you know,
my house is built in 1923 so the garage
whenever it was fucking built was built,
um,
to house like a fucking model t Ford
kind of car and those things for those
things, you sat inside the fucking
wheel wells, you know what I mean?
If you look at old cars,
um,
you know how the fenders used to flare
out and then there was just the engine
and you know,
you sat like literally like
right behind basically what you,
you sat and I can't,
I don't know if I'm explaining correctly.
You know what I mean? You sitting inside
the fucking wheel wheel wells, right?
Not like literally in them, but as far as
like the line down the side of the car,
right? Like if you stuck your head out
and you didn't have any fenders on it,
you'd be looking at the fucking
tire. Right. As opposed to, you know,
the fucking road. I know all you
guys know what I'm talking about. Um,
it also goes to show you, I like how
fucking fat and in big people have gotten,
you know what I mean?
Two things,
if you ever go to mount Vernon and he'd
go to Thomas Jefferson's house and you
have to duck underneath
the fucking, uh, the, uh,
the fuck Dee, calm the doorframes,
you see how much taller people are.
And then when you look at
those old fucking cars,
the fact that two adults could sit side
by side like that and it wouldn't be,
it probably won't even touch on
each other, you know, so many ways.
What I'm trying to say is that my,
uh,
my garage is long and skinny
and it's like high up,
you know,
and uh,
and then it kind of
flares out at the back is,
it kind of wraps around the back of the
house a little bit. So what I want to do,
the, the front part is long enough
for me to squeeze my truck in there.
Um,
but then in the back what I want to do
is I want to turn that into like a little
gym,
which my wife has all four.
And then I'm also
pitching that I build the,
maybe a little drum room
that could actually,
I got this drum kit that I bought that I
haven't cases that if I want to play it,
I have to throw it in the truck
and drive it down to a studio.
I'm thinking of making,
building like a room within a room,
which will add no value to
the house unless I someday
sell it to another fucking
drummer who also whispers on his own
fucking podcasts like his wife can't hear
it. Fucking I'm still whispering.
You know why? You know why?
Because the guys coming in like a half
hour in, my wife is asleep downstairs.
If she hears me yelling about it,
I might have to have this argument sooner
than I'm prepared to have it. So, um,
that is the game plan. And like a
couple months back I bought those holds.
Um, you know, all those things like
though that American Ninja Shit,
so down downstairs in the garage,
I want to just have those hanging from
the ceiling so I can do all that grip
strength shift that I want
to get better at. By the way,
I fucking started working out for the
first time in forever and I went to Duke
Code do pullups Holy Shit. I
literally felt like, I was like,
do I have sandbags in my pockets?
What the fuck's going on?
I did six good ones and whimpered through
the last four. I always try to do 10.
I can't even fucking do
it. It's pathetic. Um,
so that's like the big exciting
thing in my life right now.
And I got to kind of get this thing going,
um,
before my wife wakes up and find
something else to do in the house,
you know, maybe, I don't know.
So anyways, by the way, people,
I'm doing a Gig in a van couver
I'm doing a Gig in Vancouver,
uh, Canada this Sunday night.
A last second one that was added because
I left my January open because I'm
still waiting to hear
about a season two. We, uh,
meet with Netflix this week to
pitch them our ideas for season two.
Uh, so if you've already
watched F is for family.
I thank you so much because you've got
me to at least getting the meeting.
So we'll see. Uh, we will see
what happens with that. And, um,
so I hadn't booked anything in January.
So now we're having some last
second gigs, um, coming up.
I'm going to do a Gig in Vancouver this
Sunday and then I'm going to do a couple
of dates, one or two dates I think right
before the Patrice O'Neal benefit. Um,
in the tristate area.
We're still,
I'm trying to fucking iron
those things out as we speak.
Jesus Christ fills, spit it out.
All right, let's get to the, uh,
the questions of this
week. Uh, all right. Inbox,
inbox, inbox. Where's the content is
the co no, I had it on the other page.
What am I doing? Oh, there we go. All
right. Bill Patriots first. Kansas City.
Hello there. Mr. Barr. How's it going?
You freckled cunt there? How I, yeah,
I hope your holidays were just peachy.
Same to Cleo in Nia. Uh, today.
I just wanted to hear your honest and
objective thoughts about the matchup
between your paths in
my chiefs this weekend.
I was just listening to your
podcasts from 12, seven, 15. We'll,
you said Casey won't win. Shit.
Somebody tweeted me that. I said that.
I talked so much trash, I don't
even remember saying that. Uh,
and I'm content that you may eat those
words this week. Oh, absolutely. Oh,
I absolutely might eat those
words this week. Uh, but
having said, I think I might,
well, Casey, what, when Shit is,
you're not going to win the super bowl.
That's what I mean. My pick
is, uh, the Seattle Seahawks,
which is not really a, uh,
it's not really a genius pick
by any stretch of the means.
They've been there two fucking
years in a row. Um, I mean,
didn't they win yesterday
without Marshawn Lynch?
I was running back and
forth trying to make lasagna
noodles. Uh, as far as I know,
I didn't see Marshawn lynch in there.
My wife was also clicking back and forth
to like the fucking Golden Globes. So,
um, I just know that they, uh,
now when our weight, that was,
that was the earlier one dude,
you know, yesterday I watched,
I watched fucking Ohio state,
Indiana.
I watched two playoff football games
and I watched half of a Celtic game and
fell asleep was fucking ridiculous.
So I'm trying to remember what the
fuck I saw this weekend. But, um, no,
I don't think it's going to be an
easy a, listen, I gotta tell you this.
If we were fucking healthy, we would
kick the shit out of you. All right?
If we actually had an offensive line and
Edelman was back and Amygdala was back,
we had a fucking running game and
we, we, we've, we were healthy.
This is no fucking contest at home.
You know it and I know it right now,
Brady is driving a fucking rental car.
So you might go in there and beat us and
then you get to get all fucking excited
and loud, and then, you know
what? I Dunno. You know,
why would I root against you guys?
Hey, you know what you guys have,
you guys haven't won
since what, 1970 right?
What was that? Uh, what was
that fucking Hank Sram call
power trap. Cross 57 five and drive.
What the fuck was that thing called?
I don't remember. You guys have an
a, when you beat the fucking Vikings,
Jesus Christ going way back,
you beat the AFL team.
That fucking sold off.
Maybe that's why they're cursed.
Maybe that's why they've lost, what did
they lose? Three, three, four Superbowls.
Three Superbowls. Right? They
lost through the fucking chiefs.
They lost to the pack.
Is
they lost to the dolphins and they lost
to the Steelers. Is that right? Wait,
the dolphins lost to the cowboys.
Then they
beat the vikings and they beat
the Redskins. That's right.
She speak the Vikings Green Bay B.
Yeah. The chiefs. They didn't
beat the Raiders. Did they?
They beat the vikings right
now. The Vikings would have
been in the NFL by then.
I don't fucking room. Whatever. You
lost like fucking three of them.
Maybe because you'd get,
you didn't stick with the AFL guys.
Does that make any sense? Whatever.
Good luck to the chiefs this week.
Good luck to the Patriots. Obviously
my heart is with the Patriots, but uh,
you know,
I don't know.
I didn't lie like that dolphins
game where every time Brady,
the few times he went back to pass,
it was just somebody writing his
grill every fucking time. Um,
but whatever the end of the fucking day,
we have the greatest fucking quarterback
and coach of all fucking time.
So go fuck yourself. I think we're
going to be, yeah. All right.
It'd be no fun if I said good luck
to you guys. So fuck you guys.
You don't stand a chance there.
Now if you'd beat me,
you got something to talk about,
then he could trash me and I can fill
out a fucking hour next week on the
podcast. Um, all right. Drive
to school. Oh, by the way,
Alabama. Clemson, I have no, I
don't know shit about either team.
I was so fucking busy in the
fall. I didn't get to watch
any of it, but of course,
mmm. I wouldn't care if Alabama won,
but Clemson hasn't one in a while.
So I'd love to see them win.
However, if, if Alabama wins,
it just makes the Cleveland browns
futility even funnier to me because
the dumbest fucking move ever.
Do you realize that they
had bill Bellacheck and Nick
Saban coaching their team
and they fired the,
the Vus,
the fucking Paul Brown,
Vince Lombardi of the modern day
NFL and the Paul Brown bear Bryant,
Vince Lombardi
of Ncaa Division One football.
They had them both coaching together
and they fired.
So if Alabama as a Cleveland Brown fan,
you have to be rooting for Clemson.
You just have to,
you guys have had enough
fucking pain. Right? Who knows,
maybe Lebron can get you over the hump
this year, you know, uh, roof a Cleveland,
like I said, I have relatives, you know,
family that grew up out there
and all the type of shit. I, uh,
I actually loved Cleveland.
So, um, however, I also love
a good joke. So if Alabama,
Winston, and it'll still be
funny. Anyways, continue one
drive to school. Hey Bill,
I've been a fan of yours since the
O and a days and Chappelle show.
Somewhere along the line I had a kid
and he's old enough to listen to some of
your podcast. Uh, I listened to it
with him on the drive to school.
I listened to the whole episode before
beforehand and cut out any of this stuff
that is a bit heavy or sexual, uh,
Jesus, you're fucking great dad.
When you start editing that content,
you know, look at you, you're a regular,
typical, uh, not because
I'm sheltering him,
but because he and I don't need,
don't need certain podcast moments.
When you talk of ges in some
skank before 8:00 AM exactly.
Let the kid have a childhood,
uh,
trying to keep it light and positive
with the exception of the funny negative.
Anyways, I wanted to tell you that
it's the best thing we got going.
We listened to about 15 minutes a day.
It puts him in eye and a laughing mood,
which he needs schools a lot of work
these days and he always got a ton of
homework and projects and his dragon
in the morning. This wakes them up.
Sometimes we pause and talk about certain
things or all explained certain stuff
to him about politics, sports, et
cetera. Yeah. In other words, correct.
The dumb shit that I said, all
that fathers, sons stuff. Uh,
thanks for the parental
assist. Ah, that's great.
Who would have ever thought my
ignorance could be hot, warm?
Um, anyways, uh,
I'm already regretting fucking
making funny record your face.
Why did I do that shit? But you
know what I mean? He's making fun.
Everybody on the show.
It's only fair, right?
Okay.
Does showing up with fucking acceptance
speeches and he's got all those fucking
zingers at him and his writing
staff wrote. It's only fair.
That's why I like Mel Gibson. They'll
give some, gave him shit back.
I don't understand why people just go
out and smile and they should fucking
trash them. A vasectomy. Ah, dear bill,
I don't want to get a vasectomy.
I just don't,
my wife and anyone else who chimes in
on the subject started trying to break
down positives and point out
the lack of negatives ever.
Just not want something.
I just don't want one.
Can you believe this or you with everyone
else said it must be rooted in some
fear, et cetera. Fuck Dat dude. Fuck that.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Do you think you could fucking tell a
woman what the fuck to do with her body
for two seconds before she just said,
you're a, you're a chauvinistic.
Cont yeah, dude. Fuck that. Fuck that.
All Day long. That's your fucking
Dick and balls. All right. Dot.
That they fuck with your deck.
If you don't fucking want them
to go in there and snip, snip,
whatever the fuck I've even looked up
the operation, I still don't get it.
I don't get it.
Nothing comes out.
So does it stop your
ability to make judges,
do they put an order down there where
you got to milk the ges out as allow?
That's disgusting. I, I don't get, I
don't get what happens, but fuck that.
Fuck that. Fuck that. Just just
sit down with you. I say, listen,
I don't want to do that. And she'll be
like, why? Why not you? You're just,
you're just fear based.
It's like, no, it isn't.
I don't want to be walking
around and it like, dude,
you know what that's like.
You like a muscle car and they want to
rip the engine out and put a Fucking v
six in there,
fuck you and keep you Shelby badge on
the side of your car and every day in the
morning you wake up standing there looking
at yourself after he got out of the
shower, knowing that it's
a lie. Fuck that dude.
Fuck you. Keep the bullets of that
gun. All right. She can't handle it.
You know, I said, you know,
what is she going to do to you?
Huh? She gonna hold you down and make it
while someone else does it. Just, yeah,
you don't want one dude.
You don't want one to the level you're
reaching out to a fucking podcast.
Okay,
okay.
Do you understand that?
Would even use that and make
your argument just be like,
I don't play this audio though.
I would just say, listen,
I so do not want to do this,
that I actually wrote into
a podcast to get advice.
That's how much I don't want to do this.
And then she'll just be like, well,
maybe we need to go
talk somebody about it,
which means she's going to set up an
appointment with somebody who agrees with
her all cause she's gonna set up
the appointment, gone. Listen,
my husband needs to get a vasectomy.
He's very nervous.
He says he doesn't want to get it,
but I,
it's going to be the best for us and
she's going to totally set the fucking
table. It's like those dumb
fucks that go on, Doctor Phil.
Do you ever see those sad sacks that go
on that fucking show with their wife?
Like they have a fucking prayer
doctor? Phil's audiences, women.
So he's going to have to side with the
woman every fucking time. Even if he,
you know, he's going to try to, you know,
hide his hand and give her a little
bit of Shit. But at the end of the day,
he's going to be looking at you go,
you need to get your balls snipped right.
He's going to come at you like
that while he sits there, you know,
with his junk still fucking working.
You know, he's got a giant fucking unit.
Doesn't he do that big fucking goof,
that big bulk goof.
Walk down the hall that you know,
he's got a fucking giant fucking unit.
Big Gray, great Dane
balls. I don't know why.
I think he's got a fucking giant
unit. He does. He's just like,
he's just dug. But uh, the
way he talks, he's just, God
always gives them big dicks.
It just, I don't know what it is. Um,
well this giant size 16 brown wooden
wingtips just sitting across from you.
That's gotta be the worst
fucking show evidence. Oh my God.
I never thought about doctor Phil's junk
before you see that it takes somebody
to fucking bring up a vasectomy, you'll
never be able to think about him again.
Megan, my big Dick say, you
need to listen to your wife.
All right. Jumping out
of a plane. Hey Bill,
where are you at on
jumping out of a plane? Uh,
if you're a chicken shit American,
I'm a Brit.
How much money would it take you to jump?
Uh,
I got a bet with my mate that you hate
heights and it take 500,000 US dollars.
Don't change your answer to be contrary
to what I just guess. Keep it fair.
Good sir. Thanks Jesus.
Another arrogant Brit.
These guys think they're fucking geniuses.
Um,
I've already done it. You fucking
idiot. And I paid someone to do it.
I went to a,
at Pepperell,
Massachusetts when I was 19 years old
and I didn't do a tandem jump either.
I did a static line jump. I've told
this story on the podcast, sir,
if you're a little bit, um, more up on it.
Uh,
and also I have a pilot's license.
I fly helicopters. So if I was afraid of
heights, I mean, I'm afraid of heights.
Look, if I don't have a parachute
on my back and I'm not in a, in a,
in a vehicle that's designed to fly,
okay,
then yes, I'm afraid of
heights. Like, I don't like, uh,
you know,
like if he should,
like one time I watched a youtube video
and they just showed these guys that had
the climb up to the top
of this fucking building
and then,
no, not clients. They took the elevator,
who's getting hope? They, they,
they were on the roof and it
was already on the fucking roof.
This building was so fucking
high up and you know,
the wind up there must be ridiculous.
I would literally just lay down in the
fetal position and crawl back to the
fucking door that leads to the stairwell,
reach up to the handle and
fucking go back down. But this,
this dude,
mmm.
Then climbs the fucking,
the, the, the whatever,
the radio tower or whatever and it just
keeps getting higher and higher and
higher in the tower gets smaller and
smaller and smaller and he's hooking and
unhooking his safety line.
I literally,
I couldn't find,
I mean obviously the guy live cause it's
his GoPro on his helmet and I've never
been so fucking unsettled watching
something in my life. Okay.
Then I would hate heights. But I think at
that point everybody hates heights. But,
um, yeah, when I was 19 years old,
I went to this place in Pepperell,
Massachusetts,
which I don't think exists anymore.
They might still be an airport
there and they had a, uh, uh,
school and uh,
I did the static line jump.
If you've ever seen that movie,
a Fandango when a Kevin Costner's earlier
ones where the dude from a breakfast
club, uh, Judd Nelson,
his character jumps out.
Okay.
That's exactly what I did.
And I remember when we went up,
the command was sitting in the door,
get out,
and then he slapped you on
the shoulder and it said go.
And uh,
I remember when he said, sit in the door.
I thought he was saying close the door.
So I was reaching up, I'm sitting down,
reaching up, trying to close the door,
and he had this big smile on his face.
Like he thought I was chickening out.
I feel like I just told this story on
the podcast and then I find Rosa who's
saying,
sit in the door.
So you sit in the door and basically
it's one of those planes were the,
the wing is above the aircraft.
Do you know what I'm,
it's on top of the aircraft
as opposed to below,
which actually gives you a much
better site I would think, um,
as far as if you wanted to look down.
Um,
and then there's the support that
goes to the side of the plane. So,
and then right above one
of the landing wheels,
the wheels don't retract on this plane.
They had a welded a little step.
So you sat the fucking door
and uh, I forget how high we were at
going to say we will only like 1500.
We weren't that high yet because
you shoot immediately comes out. Um,
so you said you sit in the door,
then he goes get out and then what you
do is you reach out and you grab that
support be from the wing and you hold
onto that while one of your feet is,
uh,
is standing on that little step thing.
And then basically what you do
is literally acting this out.
So I can remember is
you then basically you,
you bend your arms and
you bring your chest,
like flush with the support
beam and then the, the,
the foot that's dangling,
you put it straight out behind you.
It's almost like a yoga pose. So
it was sit in the door, get out,
and then he slaps his shoulder
and he goes, go and you let go.
And then you, you arch you arc,
right? Arc One arc, 1002, 1003,
1000. Look, if nothing, look, reach,
pull. And when you're looking,
you're looking over your shoulder
to see if your shoot came out.
And then if nothing,
you look down at the handle,
reach it. Because for some reason
they say if you don't look down,
you might be flailing because you're
panicking because it's the first time you
jumped in the chute didn't come
out. Sorry. Cayenne pepper. Ah,
hang on a second.
So anyways,
I get out, he goes, go, I let go.
And instead of arching ice, I don't know
what I did. I just reached for something.
All I know is I started doing front front
flips as my shoot was coming out and I
felt it go by my leg,
the inside of my leg,
I felt it go by my leg.
I felt something hit that and I was
immediately thinking, oh my God,
I'm going to roll right up
in this fucking thing. Like,
you know when you put Bacon on shrimp.
And uh,
the second I had that thought like
to shoot already had come out.
And by the grace of God,
I didn't get tangled up.
I think about that sometimes.
Like how easily I could have fucking died.
Um, and then boom, you shoot comes
out and when you shoot comes out,
you don't even feel like you're falling
because there's nothing going past you
because you're above the
tree line and all that.
So you just feel like you're just
sort of suspended in the air.
And,
uh,
there was a radio and this lady just
talk to you and she say pull the left
toggle and you had to pull it all the
way down to unique cause I remember there
was this,
this big girl in the class and she
couldn't get it around her hips and she
landed across the street and a pile
of loom and dislocated her knee.
I remember that before. And then I went
up after her and I was just like, fuck.
Um,
and then they have this ridiculous,
you know when you get to the tree line
you suddenly realize how you're falling.
I think it was like 17 feet per second
or maybe 11 feet. I can't remember.
But it was really fast. It
was like basically, you know,
jumping off of a, of a basketball
rim. Like how fast you'd come down.
It had to be a little
bit slower, right? Oh No.
Cause you're not reaching terminal
velocity. I don't fucking know.
So all I know is when you hit the ground,
what you were supposed to do is look
straight ahead because for some reason if
you look down at your feet, what you
were going to do, they were worried.
You pick your feet up too quickly
and somehow break your legs.
So what you had to do is look straight
ahead. And as right as you hit the ground,
you supposed to do this little fucking
like collapse down and then this big
ridiculous,
bring it both your legs straight up
in the air and then over to your side.
I don't know why. I doubt that they
still have people do that. And I did.
What everybody else did is I came down
and the second my feet hit the ground,
I did a face plant right into the
grass and my buddy grab the uh,
the Mike from the person that called
me a dickhead, something like that.
What a dickhead or something in
the um, in the, in the radio.
Um, so yeah, there you go. So I did it.
And what are you basing chicken
shit. American art. Huh? Oh,
you tough guys over there with your
fish and chips. Have you done it yet?
500 years. I, there's nothing you can
sub. If I don't want to do something,
I wouldn't do it. It's not money that
you could give me. I know he goes,
Doug, fuck a break. Now I'm making
great money. I got enough money.
I've got enough money. I'm good to
take my life in my fucking hands. Now,
that's one of those things out. And when
I was back working at the warehouse,
I mean, granted I pay somebody when
I was working in a fucking warehouse,
I a shit, you know, let's see.
How much would they, I mean,
if they gave me, literally,
if you gave me $400, you would
have doubled my pay for the week.
So I would have done
that. Well, let's see.
Let's go back to the building
to climb up that building.
Okay.
How much money would they have to give me
a, when I was working in the warehouse,
a $800.
MMM.
And that now for that, that
building, uh, I would say, uh,
yeah, I just wouldn't do it.
I'm all right. I'm all set.
I'm all set. I, you know, I should
actually send you guys said video.
MMM.
So it's not that I hate
heights, sir. I hate,
I'm risking my life to that level.
If there's like a parachute
or something like that,
it is a bungee cord or there's like
a fucking safety line, that's fine.
But you know it going up that tower where
I have to unhook the safety line and
then hook it back up and there's
wind and shit. Fuck that.
That's too much of a risk.
I wouldn't do that, but uh,
you know,
why
don't I ain't, what the fuck I'm
talking about it college cooking Billy.
Oh, that's a great one. What a
great one. Bill it. Billy Boy D.
Oh fuck. I gotta wrap this up. This
guy's coming in 12 minutes. Uh,
I'm sure everyone is blowing you
up to make another cooking video,
so don't worry.
This isn't that I'm a college student.
I know you've lived like a college
student, India early thirties,
from past stories about living
with Bobby Kelly, us do.
We weren't living like college students.
We will live in like fucking animals.
Do you have any menu
suggestions besides pasta?
What would you mix together? I'm pretty
crew creative and I do all right,
but I'm open to some suggestions.
What's good to throw together on a
budget and on a fly. You know what dude?
I would go to, um, I would,
this is what I would do.
I would go on Youtube and I would ask
that question and you'll find videos and
then just start searching in.
At some point you're going to connect
with somebody and I feel like I'm,
you know, dropping the ball here on
the question, but like I'm not a chef.
I'm not even a cook. Um, really
early on this to this myself.
So that's what I would do.
There's a bunch of old episodes of Mario,
Mario Batali's, multiple Mario,
M. O. L. T. O. Mario. Um,
I really suggest watching those.
Just watch the guy.
I used to just watch the
show and just by watching it,
you learn things and you start
to see how things are made. Um,
and, and uh, the big thing is
not having, you just have to,
to learn shit in life. You got to have
the, the mindset of like, I'm gonna,
you know, I'm going to fuck
this up probably the first
time and that's all right.
And then I'll get a little
better like the pasta already,
just even just running it through the
pasta maker. I already have like three,
three fucking things that I'm not
going to do the next time. Um,
and by the way,
somebody gave me a great tip when you're
after you find kneaded the dough and
you put it through your pasta maker,
be sure to,
to douse like both sides with flour,
be liberal with the flower.
Cause if you don't,
it's going to tear.
It could tear when you're in there because
it's supposed to be like sticky and
elastic at the same time. And,
uh, when you run it through there,
um, yeah, you could, you could
possibly have some issues and it tears.
Then it's a big fucking pain in
the ass and then he gets sad.
You feel like a fucking failure and
you're not, he had the balls to try it.
So I would,
uh,
I go that Rachel Ray's got a great bunch
of great ones from back in the day.
Everybody always makes fun of her,
but she would,
if she had made 20 million meals,
he had a little fucking lab sheet do.
I used to watch a shit all the time.
That's great shit for
probably where you're at.
But I would also Google
some stuff like that. Um,
but it's great as a college student,
if you start to learn how to cook,
if you start to learn how to cook
right now and you do it religiously,
you are going to be a fucking beast
compared to the average person.
Um, by that time you were in
your 30 stowed, forget it.
If you add like shit,
like learning how to,
how to make a pie crust cause then
then you can make Turkey pot pie.
You can make key, she can make all of this
shit. He started making homemade pasta.
Forget it. It's fucking over. Then you
learn how to do all this other stuff.
I forget what I mean.
I made it with Nia.
I was really concentrating
on making the pasta.
She did the Bowland A's and then
she did the whole milk sauce thing.
But I just was watching her do that.
When you heat,
heated up some butter and some flour
and then he heated up some milk.
Then you poured the whole thing together
instead of using like a ricotta cheese,
um, arena, that type of shit. Um,
you use this really rich milk thing.
It was almost too much.
The fucking dish was like,
it almost tasted like a dessert.
It was so fucking good. But um, I didn't
know how to do shit when I was your age.
So I think it's great that
you're doing it. Um, you know,
you want,
how about Blue Apron?
Sign up for that shit and just,
you know,
steal some of them meal ideas and
then expand on them. If there's a,
in the earth is a style of
cooking that they give you,
then you go on Youtube and uh,
you just start looking at
recipes about that. Like,
you know what I don't know anything about,
which is weird because I loved the
food is any sort of Asian style, um,
cooking. I actually smoked some
ribs and I, and I had this, uh,
this dipping sauce that was like,
you know,
whatever Chinese or Japanese influenced,
with the fucking soy sauce and all that.
And it was,
and I was in a part of the grocery store
that I never went to and it was the
shit. It tasted great. And, um,
that's something I was kinda thinking
this year I want to get down pasta and,
and started to have some Asian,
uh, type dishes in there.
So if there's anybody out there that can
help me with that, I'd appreciate it.
So anyways, the guys coming here in eight
minutes, I get to upload this fucker.
Um,
I'll talk to you later.